the next domino to fall peter because we
had the graphic up earlier and we can
put it back up with the five vacancies
that are still out there
there's been a buzz all week that arthur
smith the titans offensive coordinator
who obviously is available to be hired
now because the titans lost he's going
to be the next coach of the falcons now
the falcons still haven't hired a gm
but it looks like arthur smith's going
to be hired to be the head coach and i
still have some trepidation about the
situation in atlanta what's rich mckay's
role how much power does he have why are
you hiring a coach before you hire a gm
it's just kind of strange to me in that
regard but you know what if they're
waiting for terry fontenot uh to finish
his run with the saints and maybe that
run ends on on sunday maybe you just got
to go ahead and put the cart before the
horse and hire your coach first but that
looks like it's the next one to go
arthur smith
the short trip from nashville to atlanta
and the interesting thing about that one
would be you know we talk about a
program coach
you know when arthur smith
first got into the nfl he coached on
the
uh
you know the second time around staff of
joe gibbs in washington
and i had a long conversation with
arthur smith earlier in this season he
was on my podcast
and we talked a lot about what he
learned from joe gibbs
and i think more than anything else when
i think back it's about
how to build a program and how to listen
those were two of the things that i came
away from
listening to arthur smith because
joe gibbs as much as anybody who's been
a coach
has had to be a coach of all different
aspects and facets of the team
and you know he really had his hand in
special teams obviously he had his hand
in off and had his hand in personnel a
lot with bobby beathard you know in the
first go around when they were really
successful
and so to me
i think arthur smith has a global
perspective of what it's like he's going
to have an uber involved owner in arthur
blank he's going to have a
a partner in a general manager and look
the one thing that you hear about arthur
smith when you talk to people who know
him well ultimate collaborator
you know he doesn't want uh he he's he's
not into this
it's my call i'm going to do this he's
one of these guys who's going to get
everybody's opinion and make the best
decision for the team
i thought coming into this off season
that the two guys are coaching season
that the two guys who were almost locked
to get jobs were arthur smith and robert
sullivan
and now three jobs down it appears as
though smith is going to get that job in
atlanta and if that happens now we enter
into
the secondary phase with all the guys
who are really interesting and you
really like
but you don't know if this is their year
to get jobs one of those guys
mike what happens if the los angeles
rams
beat green bay this weekend and hold the
packers to
below 21 points let's say and have a
great defensive game
does that all of a sudden raise the
profile of brandon staley i think
everybody thinks that brandon staley hey
really good candidate he'll be he'll be
a head coach in 22 or 23.
i don't know maybe
but you know this is not over yet there
are still some openings out there so
let's see what happens
one last thing about arthur smith that
just fascinates me there's always that
huge disparity between what the coach
makes and what the quarterback makes and
the quarterback in atlanta matt ryan's
at 30 million a year
arthur smith is the son of fred smith
the founder of fedex arthur smith's
he sneers at 30 million a year he's at
the he's at the same stratosphere with
arthur blank eventually i don't know how
much of that he's already gotten from
dad but uh you know i got to respect the
fact that he's achieved at such a high
level when there's never been that
financial impetus that for so many
people can drive them to do great things
if they come from nothing or close to
nothing that lights a fire he already
had that fire to achieve even without
the the necessity to go out and make his
own way so arthur smith could be the
coach of the falcons as soon as today
the lions hired brad holmes the former
rams director of college scouting as
their general manager the panthers bring
in scott federer one of the executives
in seattle to be the gm to work with
slash four matt rule still plenty of
jobs that need to be filled and we'll be
keeping you up to date throughout the
day throughout the weekend at
profootballtalk.com peter will have it
all broken down on monday morning in
football morning in america and who
knows maybe you'll hear something more
over the course of the remainder of the
program you never know when the next
shoe is going to drop
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports